thank you for joining us I'm John
Langley we start with breaking news a
student at Palo Verde High School is now
under arrest CCSD police say that
student brought a gun on campus Palo
Verde High out in Summerlin near Alta
and Pavilion Center Drive and that's
where we find Ryan Matthey who is live
at campus with reaction from students
and parents Ryan good afternoon
yeah good afternoon John this school is
on lockdown not even for 10 minutes to
retrieve this gun CCSD police saying
that there never was a threat to Public
Safety the student described as a ninth
grader a male who is now in custody
parents and students though feel there
was a concern police tell us a staff
member here alerted one of the two
campus officers about a potential
student with a gun around 8 30 four
minutes later that lockdown was placed
the student in question was pulled out
of class and arrested finding the gun
hidden in his backpack several parents
came to pick up their child after an
email to parents from the principal
these students saying even just a few
minutes of lockdown felt like ages
they didn't describe it they didn't say
that it was a drill or anything so that
gave me the sudden shock that was like
okay something's going wrong here I'm
also getting texts from my daughter
still that she's having her panic
attacks so here I am coming together
now this student has since been
transported to juvenile booking
according to police he faces charges of
possession of a dangerous weapon on
school property carrying a concealed
weapon and minor in possession of a
firearm police could not confirm this
Nest spark but as of now it seems police
were tipped off through an anonymous
alerting system used for situations just
like this throughout the school district
and if you stick with us later this
afternoon we have an interview with one
of the students who says he was inside
the classroom when this all happened for
now reporting live outside Palo Verde
High School in Summerlin Ryan mathie 8
News Now